Armand et Lucien texte de Christophe
David
illustration de François Carrage aux
éditions Island
Océan Indien
un petit Paillon que au joli plume
blanche et noire s'ennuie tout seul sur
la corniche
je voudrais bien avoir un ami
mais les autres
oiseaux sont trop sérieux
nous allons pêcher nous n'avons pas le
temps de nous amuser et lui dit-il un
sèchement
il n'y en a qu'un qui n'est pas pressé
il mange tout doucement
se dandinant
il est tout rond et très pataud c'est
Armand le dodo
moi je veux bien jouer mais mes ailes
sont trop petites et je ne peux pas
voler pour pose-t-il
Lucien n'est pas intéressé il semble
l'ignorer
un jour un cyclone passe
Lucien veut rigoler mais le vent est si
fort qu'il le jette sur les rochers il
tombe sur le sable car son aile est
abîmée
au secours cri Lucien entendant cet
appel Armand sort sous la pluie
viens sous mon aile je vais te mettre à
l'abri des intempéries
pendant deux jours il veille et le
soigne dans un joli petit nid douillet
je suis heureux de t'avoir comme ami tu
es vraiment très gentil remercie Lucien
une fois rétablie Lucien reprend les
airs Armand le regard partir et s'écrit
que c'est beau de te voir voler mais à
l'avenir soit plus prudent
maintenant
lucien est plus sérieux il va pêcher
avec les autres paillants que mais il
n'oublie pas son ami le dodo Armand
regarde-moi crie-t-il tous les soirs
dans le soleil couchant Lucien fait des
arabesques dans le ciel Armand l'admire
avant de s'endormir et rêve que lui
aussi peut s'envoler